- And many of your roles
that you played a mother,
do you embrace that?
- Ah, yes.
You know, it, the beginning of my career,
I played everybody's mom.
Jennifer Lewis always says
she's the mother of Hollywood,
but all of my children are famous now.
(Audience laughing)
- All are famous.
- Viola Davis, Taraji
P. Henson, Regina Hall,
Regina King, Idris Elba.
I mean, I could just go on and on.
I played everybody's mom.
- I think it was your magical influence.
- Wow, wow, I mean I
just could go on and on.
It's so great, yes.
- Well, my daughter is a fan.
So you worked with Whitney
on Waiting to Exhale.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I loved it so much.
What do you remember about that shoot,
like because I only have one
Whitney memory and it was like,
we were both at this
party and we got to be
in a picture together.
And it's my favorite picture
in all of the worlds.
It felt like cause, and we
didn't even really talk,
but just her presence. I was so excited.
Like I was so inspired by her.
So, what was your experience?
- She's so down to
earth and real and warm.
And when we were doing Waiting to Exhale,
she would never stop singing.
She was always singing in
the break, in the middle.
I mean, as soon as he would say cut.
- She was like,
(Singing)
- My gosh.
- And so, I just was
absolutely, loved her.
She was just a joy to work with.
I did three projects with
her, Waiting to Exhale,
Preacher's Wife.
- I loved that one.
- And the television show that
she got a chance to come on.
So she was just a dream to work with.
- Those two soundtracks
though, Waiting to Exhale,
Preacher's wife. What?
Oh my God.
It's so funny that you said
she was singing all the time too,
because the one time I was
around her, she and Jamie Fox,
they were just dancing the whole time.
Like in the photo they're
dancing. No one else is dancing.
We're all standing there. We're like,
let her do what she wants
to do. Like It was like,
it was like amazing. Anyway,